all right we should be live now
all right hi everybody um
i hope you're having a great juliocon
2022. um
i just wanted to quickly remind you all
to uh you know sign up for the
the conference via eventbrite and join
the conference uh platform which is
discord uh and hopefully you all have
every you know all of that set up and if
you don't please ask on the julia con
channel on slack
and ping one of the organizers and we're
happy to help
um i wanted to quickly thank all our
sponsors um you know our platinum
sponsors especially julia computing
relationally and julius technologies
from whom we'll hear from very shortly
our gold sponsors
intel and aws
and our silver sponsors uh beacon bikes
biosignals pumas ai qr computing conning
invenier metalens asml g research and
jeffrey sonoff we also want to thank our
media partners pac pac publishing gather
and versel and our community partners
uh data umbrella and
wi mlds women in ml and data science and
our physical sponsor of course numb
focus
so let me quickly kick things off and
hand it off to uh
handed off to james lee from julius tech
julius offers an auto scaling low code
graph computing solution that allows
organizations to quickly build
transparent and adaptable data analytics
pipelines
graph computing is an innovative
technology that enables developers to
organize pipelines as directed acyclic
graphs which are tags as as many of all
know
and can be applied to many enterprise
use cases including explainable ml data
processing and transformation aad and
more for julia users they provide a
dynamic set of tools to help developers
solve enterprise scale data analytics
problems and to integrate with existing
tech stacks i'll hand it off to james
lee's james lee the ceo of julius
technologies take it away james
all right thank you uh welcome to the
julius technologies presentation we're
really excited to be here as a sponsor
and julia advocate as ron john mentioned
my name is james and i'm the ceo and
co-founder of julius technologies
we're a company founded by experts in
the fields of computational finance and
graph computing
our team has built some of the most
complex data and analytics systems at
global investment firms
and we have decades of practical
hands-on experience addressing the
challenges that
engineers typically face when building
scale pipelines
you know i can remember back when i was
running a trading business
there was a model upgrade that we'd
spent almost a year working on that
produced wildly erroneous risk numbers
it took us weeks to find out what
happened which in trading terms is a
lifetime
now it turns out in our original system
there was an algorithm buried deep in
the code stack which would multiply our
output by negative one
programmed by a developer who was long
gone with no supporting documentation to
explain why it was there
but that's the nature of enterprise
computing you may have started with a
clean and simple pipeline to solve a
particular problem but as your business
grows so does the complexity with too
many moving parts and technologies and a
bloated code base
it becomes almost impossible to explain
how and why your system works the way it
does
the key problem here is that there's no
visibility into what's going on or more
specifically no data or analytics
lineage to simplify troubleshooting and
to help developers explain the output
that they're actually seeing
when you add to that the constant need
to re-engineer pipelines to scale to
growing business demands
you're inevitably left with a situation
where it's extremely difficult and
expensive to deliver data insights
quickly
now we used to call this set up the 80
20 rule because engineers spent 80
percent of their time on managing
lineage and scalability related issues
and only 20 percent on actually building
models and solving business problems
at julius technologies we're helping
companies reverse that ratio
we offer a low code solution for
building and managing data analytics
pipelines via graph computing that
supports lineage and auto scaling out of
the box
so how's this possible
we combine the best of julia and its
high performance with the transparency
and lineage of graph computing
and a low code framework that enables
easy graph creation and auto scaling
the net result is a truly revolutionary
solution for building enterprise scale
data analytics pipelines
let's be clear about what we mean by
graph computing graph computing is a
powerful technology that allows
organizations to build complex pipelines
as a directed acyclic graph or dag
a dag is a generic representation of any
kind of computing
which is fundamentally just a collection
of data transformations
any computation from the simplest
formula to the most complex enterprise
systems
can be reduced to a dag
but the takeaway here is that dags are a
perfect representation for building
generic solutions to lineage and scaling
challenges
because they natively track all the data
and analytical dependencies
the graph computing in itself isn't
enough
traditional graph solutions are
difficult to use and adapt they require
a great deal of coding and are often
limited in terms of their scalability
at julius we created a low code
framework that makes it easy for
developers to define and create
sophisticated graphs
and also automates and optimizes
difficult tasks like distribution and
resource management as a result julius
graphs are simple to build an extremely
fast and scalable ideal for handling
real world problems
so let's talk about performance
here we see the results of a benchmark
study showing how julius is ten to a
thousand times faster than the leading
alternatives
you can see as the graph size increases
up to half a million nodes
the competing platforms hit their limits
whereas it takes julius only 15 seconds
to run on a single computer
you can test these results for yourself
on our developer environment which is
free for developers to sign up and use
so now let's go through a few
applications of julius using real world
examples
so the first example we're going to show
is an accurate reproduction of a bank's
ml pipeline for credit approval
here on the screen we're showing the
process for a couple applying for a
credit line increase
so here you can see the entire machine
learning training application from
beginning to end from the raw data
to feature engineering the training of
the model
and then using the model for inference
and reporting the final results
the graph representation is very
intuitive
here the different colored nodes
represent different physical machines
the workload in this case is
automatically distributed to four
different boxes
so for example all the yellow nodes are
executed by the same physical machine
now let's look at how this application
works
in the beginning this is the raw data
which can be retrieved from any data
source
that could be a relational database
public url unstructured we have
connectors for many different data
sources but developers are free to build
their own as well
then we can do a quick visualization of
the data
we see a histogram here but we can also
measure for completeness and data
quality
and then downstream
we can click on any node and visualize
the data as of that point in the process
if we look at this node we've added a
few additional columns to the initial
data
for example one of the columns is called
liar which tracks whether or not certain
conditions have been met on the initial
application
if these constraints are broken it means
the applicant has lied on their
application form
and down the road we're training a
decision tree model
which is a standard model source from an
existing python library
so one key point here is that no matter
what analytics library you have we can
easily interface and source them from
either your proprietary library or third
party or open source library
all of that can be easily plugged in
that includes libraries written in c
plus
java r
dot net and of course julia
so in this case we're using a mature
python library to build the decision
tree
and you can even drill down to visualize
what the category decision tree looks
like
as you can see it's just a very typical
tree that branches out using different
attributes and eventually in the leaf
node you're getting the default
probability forecast for all the entries
that fall into that bucket
so it's very intuitive to visualize how
the logic works
for example we can easily see that the
most important attribute to look at is
whether this couple is married
and you can follow the logic forward
going back to the top level
the reason we have a multi-level display
is to allow you to drill down to the
smallest details if you want to see how
something works internally
but also have the benefit to visualize
an uncluttered top level to get an
overview of the process and to navigate
the graph
further up the graph we have the
forecast of the default probabilities
and we have the various metrics for
accuracy
for example here we showed the roc
curves
and accuracy rate with different views
now here we also integrated the model
documentation process into the same
pipeline
so a developer can describe the
corresponding data and analytics for any
node and with a single click
we can generate the entire end-to-end
documentation with the actual live data
populated
changing the pipeline in this case will
change the corresponding documentation
automatically
so this is really useful for governance
and control by automating most of the
manual labor involved
so this is a self-contained application
that highlights a few key benefits that
julius offers
the first is that a graph provides for
complete transparency and lineage
for any node you can just click and get
the data and analytical logic behind the
calculation
which makes the pipeline much easier to
support and debug
for example you can see what
calculations go into any particular node
you can see the complete lineage and you
can also show the dependencies
what are the downstream dependencies
that are derived from this particular
data point
making scenario analysis much easier
because whenever you change any of the
inputs you don't have to recompute the
entire graph you can just compute those
dependent nodes so scenario analysis
becomes much faster
so that's one benefit from having
complete lineage invisibility
fast scenario analysis
which comes from using a dag
so the second benefit is the auto
scaling capabilities
for this pipeline to scale the developer
doesn't have to write even a single line
of code
julius automatically takes care of
scaling and you can see that the
distribution of the nodes is intelligent
it's not distributed randomly
for example
this cluster of nodes are all
distributed to the same machine in order
to minimize the network traffic which is
critical to performance
the third benefit i want to highlight is
the low code aspect
so to define this entire application 63
nodes and rather complicated logic a
developer only needs to write 33 lines
of declarations in our low code dsl
so just to be clear this 33 lines of
code defines the pipeline with all the
connections and dependencies
so in terms of what's happening at the
individual node
each node can call any complex function
and that function can be sourced from
any library
you can even mix and match libraries in
different languages within the same
pipeline now the difficult or
time-consuming part of pipeline building
is the process of stitching these
functions together
managing the memory the hierarchies
distribution etc
julius takes care of all of that for you
so you only need to define or declare
your pipeline using our low code syntax
the pipeline is then built automatically
without much additional work on the
developer side
so i know there's quite a bit of
information being thrown your way but if
you want to do a deeper dive into the
low code dsl
with some specific applications and
examples
we hosted a workshop earlier in the
conference which is accessible on
youtube
so let's move on to the final example
which is based on a much bigger graph
that shows the scalability needed to run
a bank's risk process
in this case we're looking at valuing a
portfolio of a hundred thousand trades
so while this graph is rather large with
more than a million nodes it certainly
doesn't represent the limit
julius can routinely handle graphs with
hundreds of millions of nodes in a
distributed manner
in this case since the graph is so large
it can't be displayed on a single page
but we can still easily navigate the
graph
here we can drill down into the
hierarchy of the graph to look at the
individual trades and see all of the
intermediate steps
and how the calculations have been
automatically distributed across
multiple machines
we also natively support aad or adjoint
algorithmic differentiation out of the
box
which is useful for financial risk
modeling and also back propagation for
ml and deep learning applications
it's a powerful feature that provides
for extremely quick sensitivity
calculations
and for computing gradients
again i just want to quickly highlight
that to get all these benefits with a
very large graph a developer only needs
to write 69 lines of code in our dsl to
build this entire pipeline with over 1
million nodes
in practice the equivalent system at a
bank would comprise hundreds of
thousands of lines of code or more
so
these examples only scratch the surface
of what julies can do you can appreciate
how much faster and easier it is to
build data analytics
because we automate most of the
difficult and tedious tasks
julius can also be used to refactor
existing pipelines in a piecemeal way to
be scalable and transparent
so one of the reasons we started julius
was to offer julia developers better
tools for solving enterprise problems
the powerful combination of julia and
julia's low code auto scaling graphs
produces next generation capabilities
and speed
we're helping julie developers build
enterprise solutions in a fraction of
the cost and time
our low code framework is based on julia
syntax so it's easy for julie developers
to learn and use
and finally we provide a viable
migration path to julia by allowing
organizations to move in a piecemeal
fashion without having to recreate their
environments or code libraries from
scratch
we appreciate the opportunity to present
to julia khan we're excited to work with
this community and we're huge believers
in the future of julia and graph
computing thank you for listening
thanks james um and thank you uh julius
tech for uh being a platinum sponsor at
juilliardcon um please do check out
their sponsored forum which is happening
later in the day and check out the the
live
juliocon web app to find out when when
that is um next we want to quickly move
on to the annual julia developer survey
which i will start playing in a second
i'm andrew klaster with julia computing
this is the presentation of the 2022
user and developer survey
this is the fourth annual survey we have
conducted this year we interviewed
1162 respondents july 7th to 18th the
survey was administered in three
languages english japanese and spanish
in previous years and we hope in future
years we intend to include chinese again
as well
you can see the actual question wording
of each question just under the black
line at the top of the screen
which of the following languages have
you used regularly or frequently during
the past year as we would expect number
one is julia at 85
followed by python at 67 percent bash
shell power shell at 42
which of the following languages have
you used regularly or frequently during
the past year and which do you plan to
use regularly or frequently during the
next year
92 percent
of respondents say they plan to use
julia regularly or frequently during the
next year an increase compared with the
percentage who say they've used julia
regularly or frequently during the past
year
users and developers plan to use python
less
bass shell powershell less as well as
several other languages less
75 say julia is one of my favorite
languages an additional 17 say they like
julia for a total of 92 percent who say
that they julia's one of their favorite
languages or they like julia
python has continued its decline over
the past four years
the most popular technical features of
julia are number one speed and
performance number two ease of use
number three open source code is
available and can be modified package
manager multiple dispatch solves the two
language problem
the most popular non-technical features
are it's free
the community of developers is talented
and active the community of developers
is warm and welcoming
the biggest technical problems with
julia are number one packages aren't as
mature or as well maintained as i need
number two it takes too long to generate
the first plot number three cannot
generate self-contained binaries or
libraries such as dot exe dot dll etc
slow compile times require packages
libraries or tools that are only
available or are more complete in
another language doesn't have all the
packages i need etc
the biggest non-technical problems with
julia are related to adoption my
colleagues company or collaborators use
other languages there are not enough
julia users in my field or industry
there are not enough julia users in
general etc
thinking about the tasks for which you
use julia if you weren't using julia for
these tasks what programming language
would you be using number one is python
it's 77
followed by c plus r matlab and c
reasons for choosing julia number one
julia seems like the language of the
future elegance of julia faster for the
work i am doing julia solves the two
language problem i like learning new
languages
where do you interact with the julia
community
github discourse slack stack
stackoverflow and twitter
are the top responses
which of the following best describe
your use of julia
largest share say they use julia for
research followed by hobby programming
and use julia for work individually
which of the following types of julia
packages have you created top response
is private and not registered in a
private registry
which of the following types of julia
packages have you contributed to
including documentation or filing issues
but not created
top response is open source and
registered in the julia general registry
when did you first start using julia
most started using julia in the last
four years
what percentage of the programming work
you do is in julia
most respondents do at least 20 of their
programming work in julia
most popular packages are plots data
frames benchmark tools pluto
differential equations
how robust is the current julia package
ecosystem 56 say somewhat robust 73 say
either very or somewhat robust
which editors or ides do you use
frequently
i've seen a significant increase in the
percentage saying vs code
followed by jupiter and pluto
which cloud solutions if any do you use
together with julia
the largest share say none followed by
local cluster than aws
how helpful and collaborative is the
julia community 56 percent say very
85 say either very or somewhat helpful
and collaborative
offering julia conn online for the past
three years
has dramatically increased the share of
respondents who are able to participate
in juliacon
how did you download or install the
julia version you use most frequently
nearly three-quarters save binaries from
julialang.org
followed by linux distribution juliapp
compiled julia from source
with which operating systems do you use
julia
top response is linux x86
followed by windows mac os which are
growing
which hardware accelerators if any do
you use together with julia
42 percent do not use hardware
accelerators that's down from 50 or more
in the past three years
the largest share of respondents use
nvidia gpus
what resources have you found most
useful when learning julia for the first
time or when learning how to do
something in julia number one julia
manuel followed by youtube tutorials
julia khan presentations julia books and
julia academy
which of the following do you use as
part of your work
number one data science which has
increased over the past three years
modeling and simulation statistics
machine learning visualization
optimization
which of the following best describes
you academic or professional users were
also invited to select both
we've seen a significant increase in the
percentage who say professional as well
as a decline in the percentage you say
academic
among academics
the largest
number of users or graduate or
postgraduate students or researchers
followed by faculty research scientists
among
professionals
the vast majority say engineer or
developer
many also say researcher analyst or
manager
what is the primary industry in which
you work among professionals number one
is software i.t
followed by engineering finance
consulting life sciences and healthcare
among academics the primary field of
study or research for the largest number
is computer science followed by
mathematics
physics and biology
what type of improvements to julia would
make you more likely to recommend julia
to other people number one is reduced
startup time
how many years of coding experience do
you have
most julia users and developers have 15
years coding experience or less
the age of most respondents is between
23 and 40
we're seeing growth
in the share who are age 36 plus
what is the country or region where you
currently live or work
united states is number one
but the julia community is becoming more
diverse beyond the united states
as the share base
based in the u.s is declining the
biggest increases we've seen since last
year are japan and india
we see a decline in china but we believe
that is
largely due to the fact that the survey
this year was not offered in chinese we
hope to rectify that next year and in
future years
what is the country or region where you
are originally from
again us is number one but the share
who are from the us is down compared
with last year india and japan again
show the biggest growth
more than 84 countries and regions are
listed below
again we believe the decline in china is
due to the fact that we did not offer
the survey in chinese this year
respondents are fluent in 58 languages
number one is english just over 90
followed by german french and spanish
japanese and hindi showed an increase
consistent with the increase
in the percentage saying japan and india
the previous questions chinese showed a
decline
most respondents are white or asian
similar to previous years 87 percent
identify as men 3 as women similar to
previous years 5 identifies lgbtq
similar to previous years 31 identify as
underrepresented in science or computing
10
due to age
if you have any questions please contact
me andrew.claster
juliacomputing.com thank you
thanks for that presentation andrew um
with this we conclude uh today's live
session plea live session uh please um
keep track of the uh of everything on
the julia web app
and look forward to the keynote tomorrow
by dr hussein atarwala i'm i'm certainly
looking forward to that anyway thank you
all and i will see you all on discord